good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how to increase your
willpower rule number three is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best as
always guys if you're watching eclipse
if you hear somebody say something that
really resonates with you please leave
it in the comments below and put quotes
around it to other people can be
inspired as well also when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick with
yourself to enjoy
[Music]
Michelangelo is really a great story on
willpower and self-control he would have
beaten severely when he was a young kid
by his father his father wanted him to
be pursue more noble profession a more
lucrative profession and Michelangelo
wanted to be a sculptor and his father
beetle and his father trying to get him
off course and Michelangelo said all
want to be a sculptor finally through
his grit and perseverance and
unrelenting this Michael and his father
said you know it okay fine you're 14
years old I'm going to allow you to go
to apprentice with a Florentine master
and he will help you become a Psalter
and Michelangelo moves the floor instead
he started to study they started to
practice my goodness is a story of self
discipline and world-class rope out in
through his master in his practice and
through his suffering and through his
persistence and through his focus all of
these great lost traits that are no
longer celebrated in this world were all
too often people are card-carrying
members of the cult of mediocrity
through this practice through the
demotion he became well known he became
known far and wide he created it but
this is the beautiful sculptor David
equal to Museum of academia in Florence
you'll see David you will see some of
his other masterpieces and part of that
whole region started to honor the way
that Michelangelo was appearing and
performing as a sculptor
because of his mastery a lot of the
other artists like Raphael the
Renaissance painters became the king
jealous and something devised a very
elaborate and interesting plan to
discredit and to ridicule Eklund and
Michelangelo Spears went to the Pope
with Julius a second and they head to
the Pope why don't you get Michelangelo
to paint the Sistine Chapel and the Pope
said that was good
and so the Pope went over Michelangelo
and said I want you to restore the
greatness of Rome and the greatness of
Rome is now on your shoulders because
I want you to paint the Sistine Chapel
and I want you to make it a masterpiece
that hold the world in awe when they see
it and Michelangelo replied to the
public resent you know and not a painter
and I've never painted I'm a sculptor
but julius ii was very persistent and
eventually michelangelo satified i'm
going to agree in over four years
four hard years for years that took
incredible self-control incredible grit
we're going to talk about grimace
webinar incredible focus incredible
discipline Michelangelo created the
Sistine Chapel now let's put this into
perspective I mean Michelangelo had
never painted fresco before Michelangelo
had to paint something on the ceiling of
the Sistine Chapel the people standing
many people over look out and see great
detail
Michelangelo doubled the facts of the
painting on the Sistine Chapel was moldy
there were painters he had to deal with
the fact that the Pope was very ill and
he thought I might not get paid he
actually developed this incredible
elaborate system of scaffolding which
allowed him to paint the paint backwards
for four years on the Sistine Chapel and
he damaged his back in the process but
he did it for the arch he did it for the
discipline he did it for what it made of
it she did it for his commitment because
the great artists and the great
performers are much less about Eagle and
applause and money and they do their
work for what it makes us them as human
beings and after four years
Michelangelo's eyesight was so damaged
from looking at the images on the
Sistine Chapel that he suffered
permanent eye damage but like I said
once he was finished the world was
awestruck and what he created and now 20
million people a year go to the Vatican
and they do experience this breathtaking
work of artists artistry and human
ingenuity constructed by the ordinary
man who exercised world-class willpower
named Michael and
and so ladies and gentlemen I guess what
I'm suggesting to you is one fundamental
points the myth of the talented genius
the myth of the gifted genius is nothing
more than a lie Society SMG I don't know
if I expressed that clearly but what I'm
trying to suggest to you is the world
says the Michelangelo and the Beckham's
and the jay-z's and the
the great entrepreneur's the Carles wins
the warren buffett's
the Jack Dorsey's you know the founder
of Twitter the Jeff Bezos is the founder
of Amazon but the Mozart's the passive
in the box Society teaches us and trains
us that these people are somehow born
with special talents and what I'm here
to remind you a deep respect for all
twenty five thousand or twenty four
thousand nine hundred and twenty-two of
you on this webinar from around the
world
is that is a lie that society has sold
us to keep us all and if you look at the
science and science coming out right now
he's indisputable we're going to get
into that time but what science says is
genius is much less about I about your
genetics and much more about your self
control and your discipline genius is
much less about natural talent and much
more about practice persistence focus
gray dealing with suffering dealing with
failure dealing with laughter well the
world rest of the world thinks you
should stop genius is much more about
continuing practice developing your
craft
the first idea is to emotionally engage
with that dream each morning of your
life see a lot of people don't actually
struggle with the discipline part in
terms of the doing the thing it's that
they are not getting revved up to do the
thing in other words we got a problem
with motivation not necessarily just
discipline we have a problem with that
once in a while you hit it you do it you
do the work but a lot of times you fall
off because you're not emotionally
engaged it's like if you want a lot of
discipline you need a high level of
emotional connection and focus on that
thing that you want to work to work so
every morning what I want you to do is
just start a new visualization practice
when you wake up in the morning close
your eyes think about the dream the
aspiration the thing that you're really
after in life and just visualize it and
really get yourself emotionally attached
emotionally engaged with it think about
how great it will feel for you to have
that thing or be that thing or
contribute that thing to make that
difference just think about it allow it
to well up in your heart a little bit
get excited about it remember the dream
that's why we get away from discipline
because we're so busy with the chaos the
world that we emotionally are no longer
attached in a way that our brain says
hey man focus on this it's important to
you remember so if your heart is
disengaged it's difficult to stay
disciplined so every morning make it a
practice to actually just imagine the
payoff the benefit the contribution the
art the thing that you do and are doing
and do contribute if you can do that
more often you'll be more fired up and
you'll stay back on track number two set
up hard and fast rules in your life
rules that cannot be violated because
from a willpower perspective it is very
draining again to go back and forth in
your head so it's much easier to say
okay I will not drink soda and I'll only
eat food off of this list then it is for
you to go okay I ate really good
yesterday and I worked out extra hard
now on that dinner and they just gave me
a free dessert
okay for me to have a small portion
because that takes a lot of mental
energy to process when you sit up hard
and fast rules as draconian as this
might feel and sound at first it
actually creates a tremendous amount of
freedom in your own life to spend your
brainpower on the things that matter the
most so set up rules you must work
between these hours you need to go to
the gym five days a week for me I said
of rule I have to release one youtube
video every single Monday and that's why
I am here right now so setup rules
what's your watch hey if I'm to y'all
nothing else you better start that
what's your why you know why I do what I
do when I do it so passionate because my
grandfather was a high school dropout my
father was a high school dropout I was a
high school dropout and we bout to break
the cycle I do what I do so my son won't
have to go through what I went through
when I was at the football game miles do
one with me I saw other kids where they
fought I said that'll never happen to me
I do what I do because my daughter says
she's going to Hartford in even about
y'all how about to come here blames
y'all why cuz I'm trying to get you all
the NFL I ain't bout to miss this
opportunity this is the first NFL team
I've ever done in my life
and I'm about to lick it I'm about to
give everything I got and I will know if
I don't get another gig it won't happen
to do with the fact that and put
everything on the field what's your why
why do you wake up in the morning why do
you put on that Jersey why do you go out
and practice why your hardest task you
should set for the morning in the
morning you typically have the highest
willpower your brain is refreshed
glucose stores are pretty good you
believe been fasting overnight you're
refreshed you're ready to go you're more
likely to make smart decisions because
you can think you have clarity you're
not exhausted by the day yet so whatever
is hard for you whether that's exercise
some new thing you're trying to do try
to do it for your day before the long
day which is why most successful people
in history have some kind of smart
morning routine so they wake up they do
the most important tasks first while
they're fresh and then do the rest of
the stuff throughout the date or at the
end of the day when they're more tired
before you start to seriously build your
self-discipline the first thing you're
going to do is learn how to make it
easier on your future self to complete a
task and give it its stretching before a
run
take out your well-cast journal and
write down a task that you regularly put
off let's say
there's a big pile of dishes that greets
you every day after work and instead of
cleaning them right up you bow to the
temptation of collapsing on your couch
and leave them until the next morning
when you tell yourself you have time to
take care of them so help your future
self out write down two things that
you're going to do to make it easier for
you to complete the task the next day
stack the dishes neatly in the sink or
scrape the food off any especially dirty
plates before turning in and that brings
us to work out - now that you've started
stretching your muscles let's try a
conditioning exercise okay
now the same scenario greets you when
you return home from work you're tired
it's been a long day and the dirty
mountain of dishes is sitting in your
sink this time figure out a way to break
the activity into segments take out your
well cast journal and write down a
week's plan for how you're going to
tackle this task gradually for example
the first night do five dishes second
night do seven slowly increase how many
you do your discipline will slowly build
as well like any exercise building up
your willpower will take time and effort
but you keep at it you'll see a result
if you want to increase your willpower
you need to remember your why remember
the big game that you are trying to play
and for me this is something that I need
to do daily I find that no matter how
great a day its video day its filming
day perming I'm pumped I'm excited I
leave here feeling amazing energized no
matter how great a day I had the next
day I start from scratch the next day
I'm starting over the next day I need to
build myself up again as part of my
morning routine and ritual to remind
myself to push hard to do more to not
stop to not rest and not stay in my
comfort zone it's a daily battle and a
daily grind and I think having that
morning routine becomes so so so so
important to help you remember you're
why I think you can only force yourself
to do something for so long before you
quit if you don't like the work that
you're doing if you're not genuinely
excited about the work
you're going to do today that can only
last for so long you can only increase
your willpower to do something that you
don't want to do for so long before you
quit realize this isn't for me I gotta
move on to something else what is sort
of things that we do want to do is sort
of the big dreams that we have that
sometimes we don't end up believing in
anymore we have a down day we don't have
that big boldness or that motivation all
the time
structuring into your daily routine the
why why it's important to you why you're
going to hold yourself back where you
know you're going to fall down you know
for me especially when my schedule is
thrown off that's where I start to fall
down I'm a pretty scheduled person and I
have different things on different days
and it really really really works well
for me the system the schedule works
amazingly well for me but on days when
is interruptions it's hard for me to get
back on the schedule for the rest of
that day the next day starts new
schedule great to go but if I fall off
in the middle of one day it's really
hard for me to catch back up and so it's
either I designed my schedule so that I
don't have interruptions which I've done
for the most part but there's still
going to be those five to ten percent of
days worth something random mysterious
happens that you have to adjust and deal
with and the second way to do it that
I've been working on is having a trigger
to get you back on schedule having a
trigger to get you back into the zone of
where you want to be and so what I do is
I start my day with saying a few lines
to myself I'll say this three time and
if I can't start my day with it because
there's been some kind of interruptions
and as soon as I'm ready to start
working again as soon as I need that
extra little jolt suppose I need to
remember my why and the push and the
drive then I read it again you know I
let me read it for you I'm going to pull
it out this is what I read this is how I
start my day and if I fall off track I
get back to this I read this three times
today I will push myself to be my
absolute best to believe more care more
and try harder I vow not to let
distractions
schedule changes or fear prevent me from
being great I will make every minute
count because my time is running out I
have the ability to change the world and
it's my responsibility to do so
if you want to increase your willpower
remember
you're why
so thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because a balázs asked
me to so if there's a topic you'd like
me to cover on the next edition of
believe life leave it down in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know what did you take
in this video what did you learn the
most what are you going to do in your
life or your business to increase your
willpower did I miss something here that
you want to share leave it down in the
comments below I'd love to hear from you
finally I want to give a quick share
that the 2000 books taking so much for
picking up a cup is my book your one
word and posting that awesome picture of
you outside with it
I really hope you enjoy the beautiful
weather as well as the book thank you so
much for your support so thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
have an amazing day and I'll see you
soon
I think it's your natural responsibility
to be great
and I think for you not to do whatever
it takes to learn how to run your mind
like a superstar and to make this your
absolute best year yet I think for you
not to invest in becoming the person you
know you're meant to be
I think it's free to play small with
your life for you to go to work and
coast for you not to do things that are
difficult for you not to leading into
your fear for you not to read for you
not to invest in your learning for you
not to populate your life with people
who are better than anchors on you is
being elegant Henry and I think it's
being honest integrity to you to your
family into the world and really and I
know mostly we'll talk about high
performance and pay potential in terms
of integrity but you have a personal
obligation as you I to be the best human
being to express a gift in the talent
you were going and if you don't do that
because you've fallen into mediocrity or
because you bought a bill of goods the
world and sold you that your average
that your average that your theories
that the beckham's of the jay-z's
remitted Ellis are somehow different
from you well that's just not true and
you're breaching your own integrity and
your own responsibility and I've item
the same thing
I'll equally responsible because the
world is less of a place in your family
is less happy because you're not living
at your past and related to that
willpower and expressing their potential
and playing a genius and creating a life
that's legendary is actually the secret
to happiness and I went for a little
walk before the webinar I thought to
myself you know full expression of your
willpower isn't really how you express
your genius how do you express the genes
you're into but it's also the secret to
happiness I mean we watch breaking bad
or we drink too much or we got some too
much there's been too much time on the
Internet
we're doing that to keep it happy and
you you've read my books and you follow
me so you know I believe that victims a
lot of entertainment leaders not
education
you know ordinary people love leisure
extraordinary people invest in their
learning
I mean I look at the best of the best I
look at the billionaires and up coach
side NBA players all of my work Taylor
Swift reads my books
FC Barcelona reads the monkey sold his
Ferrari Jon Bon Jovi random on crystals
Ferrari I say that simply to share with
you if you look at the best of the best
they are the best of the best and full
of passion and exact excellence and
exuberance because they stretch because
they want to be the back let's go to
science every time you do something
uncomfortable every single time you
exercise self-control and we'll talk you
will release a neurotransmitter called
dopamine dopamine is the secret to
happiness
dopamine is the neurotransmitter of
motivation and it doesn't happen playing
Grand Theft Auto 5 it doesn't happen
gossiping at the watercooler it doesn't
happen being addicted to distraction
dopamine is released when you do
difficult things when we're focused when
you achieve a small win and you say yeah
I did